[Música]
una autopista desierta en circunstancias
normales los embotellamientos pueden ser
de kilómetros así es como se ve el
cierre de la frontera terrestre más
larga del mundo sólo unos pocos
trabajadores esenciales y camiones de
carga pueden pasar
las autoridades advierten que seguirá
siendo así por varias semanas más
probablemente incluso meses no se
permiten ni turistas ni visitas
familiares ni siquiera a los miles de
estadounidenses que solían venir aquí a
comprar un tratamiento más asequible
pueden atravesar la frontera
[Música]
y vienen mucho a canadá para comprar
cosas como el voltaren que es un
antiinflamatorio de venta libre para
algunos clientes de esta farmacia en el
pueblo de la col a 15 km de la frontera
el cierre de la frontera es de marzo ha
causado un daño irreversible
las familias están realmente de los dos
lados de la frontera tuvimos una
paciente cuyo marido estaba en cuidados
paliativos en el lado estadounidense
ella estaba bloqueada en el lado
canadiense sin poder visitarlo y luego
él murió al lado de la otra frontera sin
que ella lo volviera a ver otras
víctimas indirectas de su aislamiento
son las docenas de diabéticos
estadounidenses que solían venir a
canadá a comprar su provisión de
insulina para varios meses tengo
pacientes estadounidenses que me
contactan a menudo para saber el precio
de la insulina aquí hemos visto que
algunos han alcanzado mucho evitan comer
para ahorrar su insulina es muy triste
m
prisioneros de su propio sistema de
salud más de 2 millones de
estadounidenses pobres compran sus
medicinas en el extranjero
[Música]
pero sin la posibilidad de viajar y
algunos ahora sin empleo su situación
empeora cada día
[Música]
a lima rota y kevin re en ambos
diabéticos tipo 1 viven cerca de la
frontera canadiense principalmente
debido al cierre de la frontera pero
también porque muchas personas han
perdido su trabajo como su seguro médico
vemos que hay un aumento significativo
en el número de personas que necesitan
insulina y que no tienen acceso a ella
en este momento en estados unidos como
resultado le piden ayuda a la comunidad
me han llamado personas de mi estado y
de mi región que está racionando su
insulina
sin insulina tu cuerpo se deteriora en
unas pocas horas
y es entonces cuando empiezas a tener lo
que se llama cetoacidosis diabética lo
cual causa la muerte si no consigues
insulina
tenemos que seguir presionando exigiendo
un cambio y seguir ayudando a los que
están racionando su insulina
simplemente sobrevivir
en canadá donde el tratamiento puede
costar hasta 15 veces menos que en eeuu
las ventas en línea se han disparado las
farmacias como estas envían los
productos por correo aunque pueden
llegar caducados si la cadena de frío se
rompe algunos trabajadores esenciales
estadounidenses por su parte aceptan
llevar ilegalmente insulina de canadá a
los que ya no pueden ir allí desde
toronto james elliot y la red one
international crearon el hashtag insulin
for all insulina para todos en las redes
sociales denuncian los altos precios que
ponen la industria farmacéutica y la
inacción de las autoridades
estadounidenses
antes de la crisis advertimos que el
hecho de que un país grande dependiera
de un país mucho más pequeño para su
suministro de insulina era insostenible
los pacientes les advirtieron a los
políticos y a los legisladores y ahora
esta crisis es una catástrofe hay que
saber qué fabricar una botella insulina
cuesta entre 3 a 6 dólares que es un
medicamento centenario que fue
descubierto aquí en toronto ontario y
que sus creadores lo entregaron gratis
al mundo y sin embargo aquí estamos 100
años después y la gente está preocupada
por el cierre de las fronteras en el
país más poderoso del mundo
creo que esto es insostenible creo que
es un escándalo y creo que los
legisladores deben actuar
al igual que francia canadá tiene un
sistema de salud universal y los precios
de los medicamentos son controlados lo
que no sucede en estados unidos donde el
psiquiatra
vive y da clases durante parte del año
las grandes farmacéuticas no tienen la
culpa en el sistema de salud de estados
unidos hay muchos intermediarios
gestores de prestaciones farmacéuticas
que ganan mucho dinero pero no prestan
ningún servicio adicional al sistema si
uno es buen cliente normalmente obtiene
el precio más bajo cuando vas a tu
restaurante favorito se te da un trato
especial etcétera pero los
estadounidenses pagan el precio más alto
aunque sean los mejores clientes de la
industria farmacéutica y en realidad
financian los medicamentos de todo el
mundo bajo la creciente presión de los
pacientes desde que se cerró la frontera
algunos estados de eeuu
ahora facilitan el reembolso de la
insulina a las personas más pobres pero
decenas de medicamentos básicos siguen
siendo inaccesibles para los ciudadanos
de la mayor economía del mundo